[Music]
tough day for mr. Madoff or for this
accepted responsibility and he wanted to
make sure that his family was able to
remain safe and live a good life he's
accepted responsibility and this is for
conduct that they expect many years I
think manna Ford is entirely as a
sideshow we don't know what Paul
Manafort knows but there's no reason to
believe that anything in palmata Ford
has will in any way implicate the
president's interests in Ken Starr last
night on the show today a plea deal
officially from Paul Manafort former
campaign chairman for the Trump campaign
one count of conspiracy against the
United States we're talking about money
laundering tax fraud
failing to file foreign agents
Registration Act lying to the Department
of Justice one count of conspiracy to
obstruction of justice
that's witness tampering he faces up to
ten years in prison on these charges in
DC plus whatever he faced in those
charges in Virginia and under the terms
of this deal this is the big part Manta
Ford is cooperating with Special Counsel
Muller's investigation well the White
House put out a statement Sara Sanders
said this had absolutely nothing to do
with the President or his victorious
2016 presidential campaign it is totally
unrelated Rudy Giuliani the president's
counsel says once again an investigation
has concluded with a plea having nothing
to do with President Trump or the Trump
campaign the reason the president did
nothing wrong let's start there with the
panel jonah goldberg senior editor at
national review lesley marshall
syndicated talk radio host and molly
Hemingway senior editor at The
Federalist okay Molly significance what
we know what we think we know
well this relates to the special counsel
so this is significant that Paul
Manafort has pled guilty that special
counsel was set up ostensibly to root
out collusion between the Trump campaign
and Russia and there has still been no
evidence of that one of the things
related here was about failure to
register as an agent of a foreign
government so if the special counsel is
interested in a failure to register for
Russia that deals with the 2016 election
he should start looking at Christopher
Steele who was the British agent who was
secretly higher
by Hillary Clinton and the Democratic
National Committee to create the Russian
narrative and that was weaponized and
used by the FBI at the same time he was
working for Russian oligarchs like Oleg
Deripaska and lobbying on their behalf
to the Department of Justice to the
number four guy at the Department of
Justice Bruce or so if this special
counsel is actually interested in what
it was ostensibly set up to look into he
has a long way to go at in another
direction sometimes the president likes
what Alan Dershowitz says sometimes he
doesn't
here is today reacting to all of this
well of course they should be there's
nothing that he can testify to that
would probably lend weight to
impeachment because he didn't really
have close contact with President Trump
while he was president but he did have
contact during the campaign what they're
looking for is self corroborating
information that can be used against
Trump once he agrees to cooperate he has
to cooperate about everything there's no
such thing as partial cooperation and
Jona the question at the beginning was
should White House be worried or the
president be worried yeah I think it
should be a little bit I think Sarah
Sanders is absolutely right when she
says the crimes that he was charged with
in these cases had nothing to do with
the president the the only thing that
and I tend to agree with Ken Starr that
this maiden he made metaphor may not
have anything that touches the president
the only issue is he had to give mana
for something that mana Ford wanted for
mitt got to give mole or something that
Miller wanted otherwise Miller Warner
given him a deal now what that is has to
be a very minimum interesting now
whether it leads to impeachment or
anything I said I dismiss Alan
Dershowitz arguments about I'm not
arguing for impeaching Donald Trump but
Alan Dershowitz just simply created a
theory about impeachment declared Donald
Trump is de-facto client and then takes
whatever argument that is useful to them
to make it who knows what what Nana Ford
is offering and who knows whether it's
necessarily true but it can't be nothing
yeah Lesley here's the president talking
to Angela Earhart about Paul Manafort
one of the reasons I respect for man
affords so much
as he went through that try I know all
about flipping for 30 40 years I've been
watching flippers everything's wonderful
and then they get ten years in jail and
they they flip on whoever the next
highest one is or as high as you can go
it almost ought to be outlawed it's not
fair
are you considering pardoning Paul
Manafort I have great respect for what
he's done in terms of what he's gone
through I would say what he did some of
the charges they threw against him every
consultant every lobbyist in Washington
probably does at the time obviously Paul
Manafort was suggesting he was not going
to cooperate mm-hmm and interesting
isn't it that he said you know when
you're facing 10 years you're gonna flip
and you're gonna flip on anybody even
the person at the top telling perhaps
prophetic we don't know because we don't
know what he is going to provide agree
100% there has to be something of
substance there would have been no deal
cut either way any any lawyer knows that
but with regard to your point this is a
three pronged responsibility that Muller
is tasked with and one of which is the
Russian meddling in our elections and
mana for has relationships with a lot of
different Russians and that could be
where he is going with this obviously he
is pressured and used this tactic to
pressure mana for it to come to this
point right now and the big thing for
Muller is he was not in the room at the
Trump Tower meeting but mana fort was
and I think that's where he'll be able
to have more information to know quite
frankly if there was any collusion or
any conspiracy not necessarily by the
president remember but perhaps by
members of his campaign there is nothing
that has been released in anything to do
with mana fort that has anything to do
with Russia occlusion in the 2016
campaign
none of the charges in either of the
trials or in either of the the
situation's have had anything to do
maybe there's something mostly what's
been happening here in this very
expensive Special Counsel probe is an
investigation of fire violations so it
might be more reasonable to suspect that
he's going to cooperate against Tony
Podesta or something like that rather
than something to do well opinion we
cannot build none of us knows but to
speculate when there has been not one
scintilla of evidence not one scintilla
of anything dealing with collusion in
the 2016 election seems also a right
here's what we can say
drum tower meeting no it's a collision
but nothing compared to it and he was in
the meeting and all it needs to know
what's what was happening which meeting
which is why it's nothing this testimony
by manifold will be talking nothing
compared to the Russell dossier itself
which has yet to be investigated at all
by the molar controller program as we
continue looking at all those
investigations the Secretary of State's
is talking about the former Secretary of
State what secretary Kerry has done is
unseemly and unprecedented the secretary
care not to engage in that kind of
behavior it's inconsistent with what the
foreign policy of the United States is
as directed by this president and it is
beyond inappropriate I think everybody
in the world is sitting around talking
about waiting out president from Sir
Jerry Pompeo pretty hot today at the
State Department saying that secretary
Kerry is undermining US policy as it
stands now with regards to Iran yeah I
have a hard time parsing through all
this and which makes me tempted to give
in to my cynicism and think this was a
clever ploy ploy by Kerry to make his
memoirs interesting which i think is a
really heavy lift because parrot his
office is saying that they actually
briefed Pompeo about his conversations
and Pompeyo knew about these things I
agree with Pompeo on the surface of it
that it certainly does look
inappropriate but John Kerry has been
doing these kinds of inappropriate
things for his entire career when he was
a senator he would do this kind of stuff
people talk about him violating the
Logan Act and so it kind of feels like
he's trying to just generate buzz for a
truly unbelievable ogen Act was 1836 and
there was not even a conviction after
the indictment there's a lot of war
about Michael Flynn yes there was but
was there uproar about Tom Condon was
there up were about the GOP in the
Senate that sent on my side yes but that
sent a letter saying hey what in a sense
wait out the Obama administration you
can't have the hypocrisy here in a
different set of rules one president
over another for one party over another
John Kerry is a private citizen what he
has done is not a violation of Logan Act
and is not a violation of far I think
Logan actively part of it no I don't
care about the Logan we don't even know
what that conversation was about and I
haven't heard John Kerry say that he
told them to wait out what did he say I
think everybody in the world was saying
yeah alright less work if Mike Flynn's
life was destroyed because he ostensible
violated the Logan Act and that's what
the Obama administration officials
claimed then they should have some tough
questions to answer